speaking of frivolous women speaking of  the Biden Administration and death  speaking of Joe Biden's lack of  rationality speaking of not having a  purpose speaking of projecting American  power abroad speaking of Democrats  downplaying unpleasant things speaking  of attacks speaking of damaging things  speaking of  mothers speaking of birth speaking of  sexual impropriety speaking of shameful  sex stuff speaking of  marriage love marriage in the baby  carriage speaking of LGBT activism  speaking of women's issues speaking of a  lack of control speaking of refusing to  serve speaking of things  in which All is fair  such as not only War but love as well as  that for a segue speaking of women with  is in their names  how's that and I think that might be my  greatest transition ever